[Música]
esta foto fue sacada en el año 1984 del
transbordador espacial challenger
este astronauta bruce marcando el
segundo y estaba haciendo lo que se
conoce como vivienne o actividad
extravehicular
yo recuerdo cuando era chico y vi esta
foto por primera vez lo que me causó una
emoción extraordinaria yo lo voy a crear
que una persona pudiera estar orbitando
la tierra a 300 kilómetros de altura
con todos esos equipos de encima y sí
que yo quiero hacer eso y hoy cuando
miro esta foto especialmente en el
tamaño me vuelve a causar la misma
emoción que cuando era chico
esta imagen a mí me permitió arrancar un
camino muy difícil con mucha ingenuidad
pero que me permitió estar enfocado
durante muchísimos años y después me di
cuenta que haber estado enfocado durante
tanto tiempo tiene un nombre y mucho
muchos se preguntarán qué es un mundo
mucho té es un proceso por el cual nos
ponemos un objetivo muy difícil
que vamos a tratar de lograr con todos
nuestros esfuerzos pero que entendemos
que el camino que vamos a recorrer para
conseguir ese mundo es igual o mejor que
alcanzar el objetivo final
el ejemplo más claro en mucho el
discurso discurso de kennedy de mil 962
en universidad de rice que dice algo
como esto vamos a ir a la luna en la
próxima década y hacer las otras cosas
no porque sea fácil sino porque es
difícil porque no va a ayudar a medir lo
mejor de nuestras capacidades y
esfuerzos
lo que le permitió a kennedy con esto
fue alinear los esfuerzos de un país
atrás de un objetivo y darle
herramientas durante este camino en la
adversidad como la adaptabilidad de los
procesos cambiantes que se van encontrar
a mí el mundo lo que me permitió fue
descubrir
diferentes cosas en mi camino
y ahí es donde descubrí la tecnología
que fue mi compañera durante toda esta
vida para tratar de conseguir mi
objetivo en los últimos años descubrió
la inteligencia artificial es una
tecnología extraordinaria que va a
cambiar muchas de las cosas que nosotros
hacemos hoy día incluso de la manera que
vamos a trabajar y nos tenemos que ir
muy lejos para ver los efectos de la
inteligencia artificial hoy desde acá de
rosario- podemos verla
esto se llama visión inteligente y 3 una
de las tantas capacidades que tiene las
computadoras cuando los combinamos
diferentes herramientas de inteligencia
artificial lo que le permite a una
computadora es ver cómo vemos nosotros e
identificar cosas cómo las identificamos
nosotros acá pueden ver en la ciudad
rosario mientras caminamos en la
peatonal nos puede observar o cuándo
bajamos de un avión
o también sin que nos demos cuenta
cuando entramos en text
la realidad que esta tecnología lo que
permite es poder ver entender comprender
y eventualmente interactuar con nosotros
en este mundo ahora muchos se
preguntarán cómo puede hacer esto una
computadora no bueno la realidad es que
todo empieza con las redes neuronales la
tecnología de inteligencia artificial es
relativamente antigua tiene más de 50
años pero en los últimos 10 años un
cambio cuantitativo en las capacidades
de modelaje de redes neuronales
de la misma manera tratamos de modelar
el funcionamiento de las redes
neuronales artificiales que nosotros las
redes neuronales que nosotros tenemos la
cabeza para construir redes neuronales
artificiales de aprendizaje profundo y
muchos se preguntarán qué es el
aprendizaje profundo bueno el
aprendizaje profundo es el proceso por
el cual las computadoras aprenden a
resolver problemas y esto tiene mucho
que ver más que con aprender con cómo
resuelven los problemas las computadoras
siempre las computadoras especialmente
inteligencia artificial resolvió los
problemas utilizando modelos pero
realmente después nos dimos cuenta que
imposible modelar todas las opciones
porque son infinitas
entonces el sistema que se empezó a
utilizar es un sistema de prueba y error
que es igual que como aprenden los
chicos
nadie nos enseñó a nosotros saber
simplemente un día abrimos los ojos
empezamos a ver el mundo tomamos la
información y la cataloga muy gracia a
las personas que teníamos alrededor o
cuando empezamos a caminar nos paramos
nos caímos nos paramos nos caímos y así
eventualmente aprendimos prueba y error
las computadoras aprenden igual le damos
un modelo de datos los tomas
lo probamos con el mundo nos quedamos
con lo que funciona lo que no funcionó
desechamos y así genera conocimiento
pero eso no es todo porque hoy las
computadoras no solamente aprenden sino
que mejoran porque a través de este
proceso de aprendizaje reforzado como yo
practique para decir esta charla una
computadora práctica consigo misma para
mejorar en sus capacidades y así podemos
lograr modelos de conocimiento
extraordinarios
esto lo que está generando es un cambio
de paradigma en el conocimiento porque
hasta ahora el conocimiento nos
pertenecía solamente a las personas y
ahora lo vamos a empezar a compartir con
las máquinas lo que logra esto es que la
variable conocimiento va a pasar a ser
una variable atemporal que a nosotros
nos permite construir modelos de
conocimiento que son ilimitados
qué podemos lograr resultados
exponenciales cuando una computadora
aprende a hacer una tarea por qué quiere
decir bien esto bueno básicamente cuando
no sólo medimos el desempeño de las
personas sobre el tiempo nuestro
desempeño es prácticamente lineal y una
pequeña pendiente porque yo soy un
poquito mejor que ayer era un poquito
mejor que el día anterior por las
computadoras como recién dijimos cuando
aprenden a hacer una tarea tiene
crecimientos exponenciales y cuando
nosotros nos queremos medir en el mismo
campo de juego del desempeño con una
máquina vamos a perder
ahora muchos me dirán bueno cuánto falta
para que esto pase 50 años
la realidad es que esto está pasando hoy
día este fabricante de autos y camiones
le enseño a sus vehículos a conducirse
por las ciudades igual o mejor de lo que
lo hacemos nosotros si ustedes miran en
la imagen principal podrán ver como el
volante se mueve
de manera automática pero en los
costados podemos ver como la red
neuronal de inteligencia artificial
percibe el mundo en el cual está
interactuando para poder manejar igual o
mejor de lo que lo hacemos nosotros
también podemos ver este proyecto de la
universidad de stanford que se llama
gedex net project
este proyecto puede detectar aneurismas
antes de que ocurran
y predecir los igual lo mejor de lo que
lo hacen los especialistas este proceso
se puede replicar para el cáncer o para
eficiencias cardíacas y lo que está
logrando es que los médicos tengan
nuevas herramientas para salvar más
personas ojo hace menos de un mes
inteligencia artificial puedo predecir
el resultado de un juicio de derechos
humanos o como podemos ver que en
estonia se están usando herramientas de
inteligencia artificial para dictar
sentencia en una corte como jueces ahora
no nos tenemos que ir tan lejos para ver
estos efectos como dijimos al principio
nosotros hoy en rosario no solamente le
estamos enseñando a las redes neuronales
al ver el mundo de la misma manera que
lo hacemos
que lo hacemos nosotros y gracias a un
grupo extraordinario de profesionales
tomamos imágenes de estas
características las podemos reconstruir
de esta manera para poder eventualmente
hacer reconocimiento facial con baja
resolución
ahora si recapitulamos podemos ver que
la inteligencia artificial interactúa
con nosotros no puede ver entender puede
manejar
puede predecir va a poder diagnosticar
puede reconstruir todas tareas que
hacemos las personas cotidianamente
nos pone un lugar complicado porque como
dijimos es muy difícil competir
directamente
ahora muchos me podrán decir y
argumentar mira en los últimos años
durante todas las revoluciones
industriales y revoluciones tecnológicas
hemos visto como la tecnología le ha
robado los trabajo a las personas y
todos nos hemos adaptado y es verdad a
mí se me ocurren varias por ejemplo los
técnicos de vuelo o las operadoras no yo
recuerdo cuando era chiquito y teníamos
que llamar a otro país
primero dejábamos a la operadora esto
más o menos una idea de la edad que
tengo
pero tuve que esperar más o menos unos
30 años para poder hablar con mis hijos
con facetime
desde cualquier parte del mundo la
realidad es que ahora no vamos a tener
esos 30 años porque la inteligencia
artificial está hoy entre nosotros
y avanza a una velocidad
extraordinariamente rápida
y esto lo que quiere decir es que no
vamos a tener otra herramienta que
adaptarnos a este cambio nos guste o no
nos guste
sobre todo los más jóvenes
y a mí me parece que la mejor manera de
adaptarnos es utilizando un mundo
a mí el mundo me permitió recorrer un
camino muy difícil de manera sencilla me
dio herramientas que me permitieron
adaptarme y descubrir oportunidades y
medio herramientas en la adversidad
en año 2008 fue rendir para hacer
astronauta en la agencia espacial
europea este año se presentaron 10.000
candidatos para cuatro lugares
y su pase varias etapas de selección fue
rendir a alemania pero eventualmente no
quede seleccionado
y para mí fue un golpe realmente duro
porque cuando empecé todo esto mi
objetivo era ese y estuve realmente
cerca de poder alcanzarlo casi como que
lo agarraba
pero se me escapó y tardé mucho tiempo
en recuperarme
porque no fue fácil
lo que me di cuenta
hablando con un montón de personas
hablé con astronautas conocí a los
astronautas de las misiones apolo
aquellos que fueron la luna
hablé con astronautas que estén en la
estación espacial internacional y lo que
logré entender es que el fracaso que me
pasó a mí no era el final del camino
sino que el fracaso que me pasó a mí era
parte obligada en el camino del éxito
y la realidad es que hoy gracias haber
tenido mucho tirar podido enfocar de
hace muchos años me encuentro un lugar
muchísimo mejor
porque hoy sigo utilizando la
inteligencia artificial como herramienta
para poder seguir caminando este
trayecto de tratar de ser astronauta
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]